I hope it'll extend beyond people like
children who obviously represents a
strongly remain constituency I hope also
some MPs on both the conservative and
labour benches who in their heart of
hearts just don't believe this is the
right course of action for the country
will muster the courage to do what they
think is right for the country and not
just what they're being told to do by
their whips this is one of those unusual
votes that people will remember for
generations to come and if MPs and other
parties feel that's just wrong for their
constituents wrong for the country
particularly the hard brexit that
Theresa May's determined to pursue I
hope more of them will actually vote
with their consciences rather than with
with but you know just according to what
the whips are turn over all as a
parliamentarian the House of Commons has
to vote for this the country did not
vote for economic self harm yet that is
now the destination which where we're
headed on because of the decisions taken
by this government so I think it would
be perfect legitimate for MPS from all
sides to say no go away think again
revisit your hard brexit plans yes you
have a mandate to pursue brexit you do
not have a mandate to pursue hard bricks
okay so but you accept that it will get
through the commons what could it be a
different kettle of fish when it gets to
the house of lords and with those lib
dem peers there what is their attitude
and should they try and block and amend
I can of course seek to a men that's
what the House of Lords is it's a
revising chamber but it shouldn't ensure
that delay as well well it might delay
it a bit but I mean I really in the
grand scheme of things that you know a
little delay here there's not actually
that significant up but show you on
Marsha 31st sort of sorry to pick up on
that you think it could be delayed
beyond that for me it is much much more
important that the country pursues a
sensible approach to brexit rather than
pursues a self-imposed timetable from
number 10 and then in the long run our
kids and our grandkids will not thank us
for rushing towards a hard brexit which
will damage their life chances and
that's why I do think it's much more
important to take a little time and get
this right we could have chosen as a
country right and it is still available
to the government to change course to
say okay we're going to leave the
European Union but we're going to stay
in the single market for instance it is
choice by the government to have to have
interpreted the outcome of the
referendum last summer in such a in such
as a little hard and uncompromising way
and I think the House of Lords would be
perfect in its rights to challenge that
but in answer to your question it would
not be right for an unelected chamber to
seek to block this all together of
course i don't think the piers by the
way will have an opportunity to do that
in any event and can i ask you about the
prime minister meeting as we speak with
the Americans going to meet president
Trump the first world leader to do so do
you think it's the the right strategy
given the soundings where we're hearing
coming out of number 10 to to try and
get president Trump to say yes the
special relationship is its full blown
again and you are going to get a good
trade deal out of us but no one's going
to begrudge any british prime minister
who's trying to establish a sensible
working relationship with you know a
u.s. president whether they agree with
them or not of course not i hope she
will avoid the sort of schoolboys sick
of fancy we saw from michael gove and
boris johnson others which I thought was
very demeaning I think she will avoid
that but here's the problem he is not a
conventional US president he doesn't
actually see the world remotely like any
US president has done it since the
Second World War and if you listen to
what he has said and if you actually
look what he's done in recent days I
think we've got to call a spade a spade
Donald Trump his worldview is
diametrically opposed to our national
interest he thinks the European Union
sherdil will unravel he thinks the NATO
is obsolete in other words he opposes
the Bretton Woods sort of philosophy
that was established in the rubble and
after the bloodshed of the Second World
War which has governed our foreign
policy ever since that nations are safer
and stronger when they work together and
I think we should be under no illusion
that what he represents is a threat to
the kind of multilateral system which
we've always supported so yes by all
means have a meeting if you want a
Russian have an early meeting but I
don't think we should softsoap this what
he know represents he hasn't almost more
in line with with with what Putin and
elder one think of the world than what
you know many of our traditional allies
do and the fact that British
conservatives seem to be rushing to
choose Donald Trump over
mechel i think in the long run will come
back to home Mr Clegg thank you very
much